it's the perfect combination of luxury
and safety the 20 million dollar super
yacht named copasetic was built to
travel to ports around the world with a
range of 7,000 miles she can cross
oceans
that's why she's especially equipped to
avoid extreme weather bill says solid
steel
she has cables running from masthead to
bow that can head off a lightning strike
instruments on the all glass bridge
valued at more than $200,000 keep the
captain and crew aware of any storm
threatening we have notifications on
various different pieces of equipment
here they will give us weather by
satellite by text messaging the s-band
radar can look through the weather which
is quite important public depression
deal forecast advisory there are no
coastal watches or warning in effect
that's in the Pacific closed-circuit
television with surveillance cameras
monitors strategic spots during a storm
when crew are walking around you'd like
to see when they make it to the engine
or even the captain's chair is high-tech
when it's really rough the shock
absorber there will stop you from the
shot when the boat hit have you
personally experienced that yes inside
its luxury walls lined with hundred
mahogany the owners quarters five
stateroom Suites bathrooms with marble
fixtures a gym and a dining room table
that seats 10
copasetic may not look as glitzy as
other super yachts that's by design it's
also built to be innocuous when in the
force in our nervous so nobody would
know how beautiful it is on the inside
correct we can park next to super
tankers commercial fishing vessels and
just be part of the boating community
copasetic may blend in but she's a
standout when it comes to safety in a
storm
you